under oath
Fox News propaganda Sean Hannity admits
he doesn't believe Donald Trump's fraud
claims about 2020 and yet
he widely promoted them and hosted
guests uncritically who also promoted
those very same sorts of claims a very
interesting article from The New York
Times in testimony Hannity and other Fox
employees said they doubted Trump's
fraud claims Wednesday lawyers for
Dominion voting systems shared some of
the strongest evidence yet that some Fox
employees knew what they broadcast about
the claims was false the articles by
Jeremy Peters we will link to it in the
description to the YouTube video
November 30th Sean of 2020. Sean Hannity
hosted Sydney Powell on his show as she
had in many other interviews Fox and
elsewhere she spun wild conspiracy
theories about what she said was
corruption all across the country in
countless districts in a plot to steal
re-election from the president Donald
Trump
at the center of the plot were machines
from Dominion voting systems which
Powell claimed ran an algorithm
sometimes they called it a logarithm
that switched votes from Trump to Biden
Hannity interrupted her with a gentle
question that had been circulating among
election deniers despite a lack of
supporting proof why were Democrats
silencing whistleblowers who could prove
the fraud did Hannity believe any of
this quote I did not believe it for one
second
now if you watched Hannity's TV show you
wouldn't have heard him say that Hannity
gave that answer under oath in a
deposition in Dominion's 1.6 billion
dollar defamation lawsuit against Fox
News according to info disclosed
yesterday
Hannity's disclosure along with others
that emerged about what Fox News
Executives and hosts really believed
became one of the loudest megaphones for
La as their Network became one of the
loudest megaphones for lies about the
election this is the strongest evidence
yet that fox employees knew what they
were broadcasting was false this is not
a shock this is not a shock Hannity is
an amoral propagandist profiteer no
doubt about it but he is not so stupid
that he believed this nonsense and in
fact the totality of the text messages
that we now know Sean Hannity sent to
people like Mark Meadows and others and
this deposition under oath tells us
they were knowingly spreading
misinformation it doesn't make it any
better okay if you thought Hannity was
that stupid he's not that stupid
but it tells us he knew he was spreading
lies it's almost an even worse case for
them they weren't just gullible idiots
they were knowingly spreading lies and
disinformation and of course we know
that when push comes to shove they go
for it's not news It's Entertainment
Tucker Carlson Fox News lawyer said
Tucker Carlson is an Entertainer it's
not news the things he says are laced
with Hyperbole and exaggeration and
titillating language they're not to
believe be believed literally but in
reality it's not even really
entertainment because it's not
entertaining it's sort of BS and lies
it's a BS Factory that they pump out not
just for profit yes profit is part of it
but it's also to maintain access to
people in power Hannity we now know how
to relationship with Trump to the extent
that Trump has friends and for Trump a
friend means someone who's useful to me
until they turn against me okay fine but
that's the definition Hannity would hang
out with Trump people be on uh with
Trump's plane and all this different
stuff
it was to maintain access as much as it
was for profitability now in a
well-functioning educated democracy
where people are educated in media
literacy Etc
people like Hannity wouldn't have
careers not because they're kicked off
of the air I'm not suggesting anyone
kicked them off the air but I'm saying
no one would watch it
if we had an educated informed democracy
Now ultimately I really don't care if
they claim now to have privately doubted
the things Trump was spreading they
publicly supported it and they are part
of why there was a public willing to go
and do what they did on January 6th will
there be any consequences for this
probably not
tomorrow Friday is the day
one day membership special last discount
of the year last opportunity to
participate in the membership special
for the year your first month payment is
going to be donated and doubled we are
working with a charity who I will name
tomorrow because they told us it's a
problem for them if we name them in
advance
we're entering into a marketing
agreement and it can be a problem for
them as a 501c3 but many of you I know
know which charity it is one of the most
effective ways to actually help people
around the world is to give them cash
something like 98 of donated funds get
to people when you just send them cash
and let them figure out what they need
so tomorrow if you're on my mailing list
you're going to get an email and it's
going to tell you how to sign up at a
discount your first month's payment
we're going to donate and then we're
going to double it up to the first
fifteen thousand dollars really great
opportunity to both get a membership
help us by getting access to the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money there everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
and we are helping other people so get
on my mailing list at davidpackman.com
tomorrow morning maybe late morning
maybe early afternoon you'll get an
email telling you how to Avail yourself
of this fantastic special